you know in this moment I'm finding a
very almost kind of sick irony that
early promotion for Jody whitakerzera as
the doctor had the tagline it's about
time because that is exactly what I'm
thinking about the trailer for the final
appearance of her doctor
ah we've now also got a confirmed uh air
date of the 23rd of October so a little
over two weeks at time of recording like
what
ah
the fact that they have done virtually
no promotion for this almost no build up
whatsoever and it's taken this long to
even get a trailer and like it's a
minute it's barely over a minute
this uh I don't want to I don't want to
spend too much time going off on this
but like this
this has been really weird I already
kind of did a short over on the main
Channel talking about this uh briefly
but
if if they had not cast a new doctor and
weren't clearly continuing to move
forward with the property I would
otherwise have assumed they're going to
put the show on Hiatus again and they're
burying this but like we know they're
not putting the show on Hiatus so this
is this is weird anyways power of the
doctor first uh really proper trailer
for it
um so uh you know other than like the
little tiny teases we've had of some
things but all right let's see let's see
yeah I was gonna have to have the master
we gotta wrap that dozen of the world's
leading seismologists have gone missing
15 of the world's most valuable
paintings have disappeared
opinion okay
oh okay
has it never occurred to you that it
could be a trap whoa okay that was the
point you are a raised forever
bit of a conversation stopper huh
is that a Death Star
oh dangerous
[Music]
Anything Could Happen
hmm
this is a lot this is a lot
don't forget to click below and
subscribe to the official Doctor Who
YouTube
this makes me nervous with how much for
okay first off
uh they're going effects heavy they are
going for spectacle on this one which
um that could work I mean it's certainly
not an invalid way to do it um you know
looking back at uh final appearances for
doctors
um
RTD definitely tend to favor going big
and going for like throw ride spectacle
not necessarily visual effects spectacle
the way this appears to be doing
um but you know that that is something
that it's an option it's not usually my
preferred way to end these things out
um but it it certainly can work
um and I I think I've said before that
especially for a regeneration story
unless you're gonna get really
distinctly introspective kind of like
how the doctor falls does I don't think
it's a bad idea to approach uh a
doctor's regeneration in a kind of
roller coaster ride away make you know
go out with a bang that's not the only
way to do it but I think uh it's a
pretty reliable way to do it that having
been said there is a lot in this we see
Sasha dawan's master in several
different ways
um which really makes me wonder if he's
like if he's appearing out of time or
out of order in this uh so like that
that was kind of intriguing then we've
got dialect showing up and I'm like oh
oh okay I guess Dalek show up in a lot
of these things sometimes even even
small parts like oh okay but then shod
is back who's a character who is dead
and has been dead uh for a full series
and and then like there's the reminder
that Ace and Tegan are going to appear
on like I'm okay and it's kind of
setting up this mystery like all this
stuff's missing seismologists are
missing pieces of art are missing the
piece of art thing immediately makes me
think of the zygons again because of
what happened uh with uh Day of the
Doctor now granted the zygons themselves
weren't uh the only ones sort of
impacted by the you know it's art and
they come out of it they kind of did
that with Gallifrey as a whole in
lithotics as well but like I'm
immediately thinking of Day of the
Doctor I'm wondering if any of that is
playing in or if this is a complete new
thing we've got like two planets firing
weapons at each other we have what looks
like a freaking Death Star
what's the run time on this is kind of
my big question
because if it's not two hours
I don't know how you are going to be
able to have this much stuff these many
elements these many characters
crammed into this and have it work like
again to pull an example of uh you know
when tenet are regenerated in um end of
time you know that that was a two-parter
and you know they pulled in a fair
amount of stuff in a fair number of
characters
um and stuff to pay off but like it it
had the breathing room
it had the breathing room to deal with
the master bring back Gallifrey uh have
a little bit more with Donna do stuff
with willf address the doctor's fears of
regeneration and actually that's kind of
what I'm most concerned about
how much of the doctor
are we going to get
in power of the doctor
because like she appears in there but so
much of the emphasis is on everything
else
and yes it's it's big and it's bombastic
and it might be an entertaining ride but
like
I would really like a regeneration story
to give me a spotlight on the doctor and
I'm really worried that's not gonna
happen I'm worried that in an effort to
cram all this stuff in she's the one
who's gonna get the shaft
and she's the last one who should get
shafted in something like this and I I'm
really worried that like I'm gonna go in
and go about half these things that are
crammed in here didn't need to be here
for like for the story but they're
shoved it in the reading up time and we
lost time with the doctor
is that what's going to happen I don't
know
I don't know we'll see what the run time
is but we kind of already had that
problem with Legends of the sea Devils
which was which was marketed and pegged
as a special but basically had a
standard episode run time
and and partly as a result some of the
stuff that could have been really good
felt cut off and short changed and the
plot jumped around a bit and that was a
pretty straightforward one
I will either feel more nervous or
slightly more optimistic once we know
how long this is because either it's
going to be an hour and a half or more
and I'm going to go okay
maybe this can be pulled off or we're
gonna find out it's like just about an
hour I'm gonna go oh crap
and I don't I don't know
I don't know what it'll be but right now
given
um especially how I felt about a lot of
uh flux like would say the first episode
of that was Halloween apocalypse or
whatever it was and like how much that
felt like it was just cramming
everything that it could into the space
that's the fears I'm getting off this
but like that was you know the start and
the setup of stuff that was to come
whether you like flux or not it was at
least
um going like well here's all this stuff
now let's now let's go somewhere with it
whereas this this is supposed to be an
end
and I didn't see any sign of Joe Martin
which also makes me nervous are they
going to properly tie off that whole
concept and like look
I don't like the Timeless child I've
gone off repeatedly on the fact that I
don't like the Timeless child
but if you're going to do that
I kind of need you to do something with
it
because if you're not gonna do really
much of anything with it or if you're
going to abandon whatever it was you
were initially planning then it really
had no reason to happen
this was kind of why like I said I
didn't want Chris chimnall to
immediately undo a retcon or undercut
the idea of the Timeless child as much
as I hate that idea I want to at least
know what it was you intended to do that
you felt that you had to do this thing
with the lore and the backstory and the
and the doctor
but it with how much else has crammed in
here and basically the only thing that
would connect back to the Timeless child
being the master
maybe it'll get addressed maybe it'll be
addressed in a very well okay let's wipe
our hands of that maybe it'll be mostly
ignored I don't I don't know
I am going to want to like this because
I always want to like Doctor Who
and
I don't have a lot of confidence in
chibnol as a writer to be able to
deliver something that's going to feel
like a satisfying conclusion for this
era especially after this trailer where
it just feels like everything has been
crammed into a space
I'm still gonna be hopeful
I don't want to assume it's going to be
bad
but I can't look at that and be excited
for anything other than the visuals but
like I've said for pretty much this
entire era the show has looked about as
good as it ever has during Whitaker's
time the effects have been for the most
part quite good the shooting techniques
I thought have been quite improved and a
lot more Dynamic and interesting than
the Fairly standard shooting style that
it had before I've enjoyed the visual
presentation but that can't carry me all
the way
and most of what I got off of this
trailer was visual presentation which is
the thing I already know has been
handled fairly well for this era
I needed reassurance that the writing
was going to have Focus
and was you know knew what it was doing
and I don't have that right now
oh
I want it to be good
at the very least I wanted to be
satisfying
and I want to feel like Whitaker got to
go out
on a strong note I want that I want that
for her I want that as a fan I want that
I
I don't know if I can expect it
power the doctor
very busy one minute trailer I'm sure
some people will go through like frame
by frame and completely pull apart
everything that's there we see vendor
again which makes me very nervous about
possible Revelations that involve them I
thought we were clear you know with him
and um what's her name Belle Bell Bella
I can't I can't even remember now
um you know there was I had a lot of
concern about what reveals might be
involved in them they didn't happen in
flux I thought we were clear now we see
him again and so now I'm nervous about
what might be implied
there if they pull the trigger on the
idea that um
I'll just go ahead and say a potential
spoiler I suppose if they pull the
trigger on the idea that their kid is
the doctor which is something I saw
floated and I would normally discard but
given the other stuff that chimnal has
pulled I would not put it past him and
if they do that I would hate it and
again if that's something that's crammed
into a space with everything else going
on
if it was ever an idea that was going to
work you're not going to have the time
to sell it
yeah
yeah I'm sure other people who go
through like frame by frame break down
everything that's here but for me it's
just I just felt bombarded with a lot
that was not uh very focused maybe the
final product will be with the trailer
is not
it's selling spectacle and I needed it
to sell me story
what are your thoughts about this
trailer whatever they are drop something
down the comments let's talk about it
patreon's what pays the bills and allows
me to do this as my living any amount
that you can support me at is greatly
appreciated even if you can't like share
and subscribe help me out
um but you know don't worry too much
about it I know I'm nervous about all
this but we we do try and take a relaxed
attitude around here so you can just
come on back
next time you need a break
[Music]
all right time to thank my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Zubin
lotfulla Tarak the thing that goes doink
in the anime Oliver B Melinda Walters
emudelki Leo the boy toy lowly Becky
Sparks for novelax the poodle Zack
Bookworm Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam
RDL Taylor Shayla Gourley Brendan morose
and TT thank you for your support if you
want to hear me try and say your name
while this little guy tries to chew on
my earrings well you can check out the
patreon for the support tears that get
you a shout out thanks so much you are a
pain in my butt
[Music]